IAN LAKE: So you're building an
app, you hit the Camera button,
and it just crashed.
JOANNA SMITH: Which app?
IAN LAKE: Doesn't
matter what app.
It's completely hypothetical.
JOANNA SMITH: But
hypothetically, my apps
don't crash.
IAN LAKE: You built an app.
You hit the Camera button,
and it-- and it crashed.
It's trying to be a
better app, but it
can't, not without your help.
Why aren't you helping, Joanna?
JOANNA SMITH: Wait.
What do you mean
I'm not helping?
I am a super helpful person.
IAN LAKE: If you
were super helpful,
we would've already talked
about adding runtime checks
to your Implicit Intents.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOANNA SMITH: Fun fact,
Implicit Intents--
IAN LAKE: --like
opening the camera app.
JOANNA SMITH: Right.
Implicit Intents may not
work on every device.
IAN LAKE: Well,
it's not that they
won't work on every device.
It's that on some devices, the
apps you need may not be there.
For your plea of help.
JOANNA SMITH: Right.
And that would trigger an
ActivityNotFoundException,
which is certainly not
good news for your app.
IAN LAKE: That sounds
super serious, like,
kill your app serious.
JOANNA SMITH: Right.
It could cause
your app to crash,
and that would
generally happen when
the app is missing because
the user has uninstalled
or disabled the application.
IAN LAKE: What?
Uninstalled?
Disabled?
Like, my favorite applications?
JOANNA SMITH: Mm-hmm.
Or it could be that
the user's what
we call a restricted profile
and doesn't have access
to all of the features.
IAN LAKE: Restricted profiles?
Is that serious?
Like, do we need to get
someone to look at that or?
JOANNA SMITH: Or it could be
that the device administrator
has restricted which
apps and features are
available to the users.
IAN LAKE: So a
device administrator
could take away my camera app?
JOANNA SMITH:
Well, I mean, yeah.
But keep in mind that
devices for work environments
or devices with
parental controls
may not need a
camera functionality.
IAN LAKE: Ah, but we can
still take selfies, right?
JOANNA SMITH: Um.
IAN LAKE: Oh, it crashed.
JOANNA SMITH: Right.
So to prevent runtime
exceptions and untimely crashes
is actually really
easy if you just
call ResolveActivity before
launching your Implicit Intent.
IAN LAKE: ResolveActivity,
problem solved.
We're done.
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah, it really
is actually as simple as that.
Because just
checking to make sure
you have something
to use before using
it will make your whole
application more stable.
IAN LAKE: Wow.
That's great.
Does that mean we
can take our selfie?
JOANNA SMITH: Uh.
IAN LAKE: Selfie.
Wow.
That's good.
JOANNA SMITH: Right.
So use runtime checks to--
IAN LAKE: --build better apps.
JOANNA SMITH: Build better apps.
Thanks, Ian.
[MUSIC PLAYING]